[Musica]
lavoro in aziende da anni in aziende
abbastanza grandi quindi complesse e mi
occupo anche lavorando alle vendite di
clienti altrettanto complessi e quindi
inizialmente ho detto ma vuoi che parli
di qualcosa relativo al mondo
professionale mi ha detto quello che
vuoi
e allora ho detto ho pensato di parlare
di un'altra cosa che mi sa che ha
colpito mi ha cambiato la mia vita molto
di più rispetto a quella che può essere
la carriera perché comunque di resilenza
si parla spesso
sicuramente tutti in realtà piccole o
grandi andiamo al lavoro tutti i giorni
e quindi tutti facciamo l'esperienza
della resilienza nel posto di lavoro
io diciamo che ha avuto un'esperienza
personale di cui amo parlare perché può
essere una cosa che
di cui non aver paura e soprattutto che
può essere utile a tutti e mi sembrava
un'ottima occasione questa circa sei
anni fa era al febbraio del 2015
mi è stata data quasi per caso perché
non me l'aspettavo assolutamente in un
controllo di routine è stata data una
notizia che da lì a tre settimane mi
sarei dovuto operare di tumore al seno e
dico proprio tumore cancro perché mi fa
un po tristezza quando viene chiamato
appunto un brutto male e lo devo anche a
mia madre che fin da piccola un po
perché ero figlia unica doveva essere
abituata tutto ad affrontare le cose
belle e brutte della vita mi ha sempre
detto mi ha sempre spiegato sia le cose
appunto di cui gioire ma mi ha anche
fatto capire quali sono le cose di cui
non aver paura nella vita perché bisogna
affrontarle e diciamo che io in quella
situazione
ho anche fatto un po ridere tutti i
medici perché l'area prima reazione è
stata quella di prendere dalla borsa
proprio il telefono del lavoro non
quello personale guardare l'agenda io ho
detto no ma io prossime tre settimane
sono piena di impegni io proprio no mi
spiace dobbiamo pensare un altra data
e poi vabbè questa cosa è continuata nel
rapporto coi medici perché ho fatto un
po la giullare per tutta la degenza al
dopo insomma quindi mi è stata anche
d'aiuto poi insomma non ho difficoltà a
fare amicizia quindi nel reparto mi
conoscevano un po tutti
che dire sicuramente appunto lì dopo lo
shock iniziale e anche appunto un po la
rabbia la negazione che è quello che
avviene sempre in questi casi perché poi
io mi sono letto diverse cose diverse
esperienze ed è una parte importante del
processo appunto di riconoscimento anche
della malattia
ho detto io la prima cosa assolutamente
che non voglio e non voglio essere
identificata come una malata voglio
stare fare questo percorso e essere come
sempre essere normale tra virgolette e
quindi sia durante dopo l'operazione poi
ho fatto la chemio
ho sempre fatto tutto quello che facevo
prima anzi di più cioè proprio invece di
fare era uno strafare
andavo agli aperitivi alle cene uscivo
facevo sport ha continuato andare a
lavorare sempre a parte i pochi giorni
in cui magari non stavo proprio
benissimo perché dovevo sentirmi che ero
ancora io e lidi ci va bene ok 6
resiliente e continui andare avanti
anche perché questa spinta innata
probabilmente a alla sopravvivenza
in realtà quello che non m'aspettavo è
che il difficile è venuto dopo
quando tutto era finito perché mi
ritrovavo davanti un mare di opportunità
perché avevo la vita di nuovo davanti è
però per me più che un mare di
opportunità
era un oceano spaventoso perché avevo
perso tutte le mie certezze tutte le
basi su cui avevo fondato la mia vita
avevo proprio bisogno di ripartire da
zero e di resettare tutto e di
riprendere da zero proprio tutto quello
che avevo fatto fino a quel momento
sapevo che avrei cambiato stavo
cambiando e avrei cambiato completamente
la visione della mia vita però non
sapevo ancora come e questo era per me
il disequilibrio che avevo internamente
e quindi ho cominciato anche lì a
strafare perché ho cominciato ad andare
sempre frequentavo fortunatamente ho
avuto una serie di affetti vicini molto
intelligenti molto sensibili che mi
hanno accompagnato veramente in questo
percorso e devo dire che questa è una
fortuna ho frequentato persone nuove
anche ho perso qualcuno per strada ho
iniziato nuovi hobby
ho iniziato anche a fare volontariato
che prima non facevo però ancora non mi
bastava e ho detto ricominciamo da
quella che la mia passione è
fondamentale i viaggi anche perché
diciamo che l'hanno della chemio io
dovevo andare in
indonesia e dare un viaggio che sognavo
da un bel po e mi hanno detto no quindi
io ci sono rimasta abbastanza male
l'anno dopo i miei amici dei viaggi
abbiamo questo gruppo proprio con cui
facciamo da anni dei viaggi molto belli
un po zaino in spalla non è una cosa fu
organizzata
siamo andati in uganda ruanda quindi tre
settimane sono abbastanza impegnative
sia dal punto di vista fisico perché ci
siamo fatti esperienze su e giù per la
giungla cercare i gorilla vedere i
gorilla ma poi anche esperienza appunto
genocidio in ruanda quindi è stata
un'esperienza veramente fisica ma anche
mentale e devo dire che da un lato mi si
è ristorato il corpo perché ho
cominciato a buttare giù tutta la
stanchezza che avevo accumulato
nell'anno prima ma anche la mente perché
io mi nutro tantissimo
sono molto curiosa di cose nuove di cose
diverse
quindi lamentela ritrovato un pò
l'energia appunto con nuovi stimoli
i nuovi paesaggi risate con gli amici di
sempre e quando sono tornata in realtà
quello che ho capito era che il viaggio
dentro me stessa il viaggio personale
iniziava in quel momento avevo
ricaricato le batterie ma adesso dovevo
proprio ripartire e
la cosa che diciamo
bisogna fare per non perdere la
resilienza e non metterla in pericolo è
curare le ferite del passato perché io
le avevo semplicemente messe da parte
rimosse e quindi ho cominciato ad avere
questa consapevolezza
innanzitutto che dovevo un po mettere da
parte quella che era la mia tra
virgolette indipendenza la voglia sempre
di fare le cose da sola che dovevo
affidarmi a gli altri anche che non era
una debolezza ma anzi era una cosa
invece una forza anche quella e quindi
dovevo fare questo percorso con gli
altri si sa che mi è sempre stato vicino
nei momenti difficili e comunque da
sempre sia poi con qualcuno di
professionale perché ho iniziato
naturalmente un percorso anche con una
magnifica psicologa ma soprattutto
perché dovevo appunto ritrovare delle
nuove consapevolezze e un nuovo
equilibrio e da lì
ripartire e quello che diciamo è stato
fondamentale è stato il fermarmi perché
io fino a quel momento avevo sempre
corso corso mille cose mille idee mille
progetti per me quella della vita sempre
andare avanti continuamente allora io di
certo non dico appunto che rifarei
l'esperienza del cancro non lo dico a
nessuno mi viene un po da ridere quando
si sentono sente qualcuno che dice ah è
stata un'esperienza che mi sa che
assolutamente è stata fondamentale nella
mia vita anche no
cioè per chiunque però devo dire che
quello che non rinnego ha fatto il
percorso che poi mi ha fatto fare è il
consiglio che do a tutti è quello di
quando mi quando ne parliamo di imparare
a fermarsi perché fermarsi non è una
debolezza chiedere aiuto agli altri non
è una debolezza ma è anzi ricostruire
proprio la propria resilienza appunto e
la propria resistenza perché non ce la
possiamo sempre fare da soli e
soprattutto siamo in un mondo che corre
corre corre ma in realtà ogni tanto
appunto è proprio necessario stare fermi
e nello stare ferma
ho ristrutturato tutta la mia vita
perché nel giro di appunto dal 2015
diciamo che proprio un po meglio ho
cominciato a stare nel 2017 da lì una
serie di eventi positivi cambiato casa
cambiato lavoro cambiato fidanzato ho
cambiato un po tutto
e devo dire appunto che non è tanto
quello che faccio perché ad esempio a
livello lavorativo più o meno insomma il
lavoro e quello è cambiata l'azienda a
livello di
di città abito sempre a milano ho
cambiato casa li avessi danzato l'ho
cambiato no quello proprio cambiato
tutto è però devo dire che la cosa
diversa e che sono ripartita proprio da
me e soprattutto sono ripartita dalle
cose pensando sempre per ogni decisione
sia personale che professionale a quello
che piace a me
prima ero molto più nelle mani del mondo
che girava anche delle convenzioni
sociali invece sono proprio ripartita da
me da quello che mi piace e qualsiasi
scelta che faccio adesso
prima chiedo ma a me fa bene ma è
positiva per me mi farà stare bene e
questo anche nel lavoro ad esempio
perché quando ho cambiato lavoro più o
meno tre anni fa appunto io l'ho detto
subito al mio capo al mio quello che
sarebbe stato il mio capo quindi ancora
prima che loro scegliessero se io dovevo
essere la persona giusta o no
ho spiegato la mia situazione ma in
positivo e io proprio detto io ho questa
cosa mi ha fatto cambiare proprio la
prospettiva quindi io sono una persona
che lavora che ha la passione per il
lavoro ma c'è altro quindi sappiatelo
perché io vi voglio mettere a conoscenza
di questo se sono la persona giusta con
queste anche con queste caratteristiche
va bene ma non voglio assolutamente poi
che ci siano delle cose per cui appunto
magari questa è un ostacolo quindi sono
stata chiara senza paura di non essere
presa di perché ho detto se mi dicono sì
devo essere sicura che il posto per me
con le esigenze che ho adesso e ci devo
stare bene quindi quello che vi dico
appunto esperienza negativa trasformata
in esperienza positiva
spero proprio di sì e appunto anche
nell'esperienza adesso di in
quest'ultimo anno con il covip mi sono
ri fermata di nuovo ma questa volta
sapevo già che sarebbe stato qualcosa
che avrebbe prodotto dei frutti positivi
e infatti anche questo facendo delle
cose nuove insomma che fra un po
verranno
la luce al di là del lavoro
e diciamo che appunto
sono un po rinata da dal 2015 in poi
[Applauso]